hello everyone i'm speaking once again
today with dr frederick w kagan who's
the author of a number of books related
to history and foreign policy he also
worked as an assistant professor of
military history at west point from 95
to 2001
and as an associate professor of
military history
from 2001 to 2005 he holds a phd in
russian and soviet military history from
yale
after we spoke a few days ago and you
can
refer to that video for more in-depth
discussion we decided that an update
on the situation in ukraine
uh now and then might be useful and so
this is perhaps the first of those and
so
thanks for talking to me again dr kagan
and i'm all ears what's what's happening
in ukraine what's happening around the
world how do you see the situation where
are we going
well thanks jordan thank you for having
me on and thank you for having me back
um it's a it's a privilege to be with
you
um and speak with your uh with your
audience about this uh thank you for
staying on this topic
um
so
amazingly the ukrainians are still in
the fight uh in the conventional war
against the russians uh a week into it
no one who uh is familiar with the
militaries of either side
uh or who is familiar with basic
practices of net assessment um
would have would have guessed that the
ukrainians would still be in a position
uh whether they have held their capital
they've held kiev
uh they've prevented the russians from
taking the second largest city in
ukraine harkeef
they have lost ground in the south
they've
probably lost the city of harassan
they're probably going to lose the city
of mariupol
but they have not lost any other major
city
and they've inflicted fearful losses on
on the russian invaders
um and have been able to beat off
repeated russian mechanized attacks and
airborne attacks
um how have they been able to manage
that and why is it such a surprise
well you know when you do when you cast
a sort of a basic net assessment
uh you you count things like tanks and
aircraft and
artillery tubes and rocket launchers and
stuff and you look at the degree of
modernization of both sides and what
kind of equipment everybody has and then
you look at the numbers of troops and so
forth
and by all of those measures the russian
superiority
is so overwhelming
that you
you know all of your basic net
assessment calculations would say that
the russians should have been able just
to roll over them
and the russians seem to have thought
that they would just roll over them and
that's a big part of the explanation for
why things have gone the way that they
did
it's really become very clear that the
russians just did not expect that they
were going to be in a big fight here
they they thought that they were going
to roll in the ukrainians were going to
run away or surrender and they russians
thought they were basically going to be
able to drive into kiev and other cities
and and do their will
and i think they've been very much
surprised
by the fact that the ukrainians have
just decided to fight like lions
um and have been also very skillful at
it
and then
there are some other factors that are
important here too that um
it's not obvious to me that when the
russians when the russian military put
the forces in place
that have conducted this invasion
they actually thought that they were
going to have to conduct the invasion
i think that it's very possible that the
initial deployments that they made
were actually done more to generate
psychological effects on ukraine in the
west in support of other things that
putin was trying to do
and certainly we know that russian
soldiers were surprised when they were
told that they were actually going to
invade ukraine
but i i think it's possible that there
were there have been points over the
past few weeks when russian more senior
officers
were told that they were really going in
and and were
um you know were probably taken aback
because they really
they just the russians made a lot of
mistakes in the way that they've set up
to conduct this operation and they've
made a lot of mistakes in the way
they've conducted it and the ukrainians
have made them pay for almost every one
of those mistakes
so what's happening in russia more
broadly there were demonstrations which
is always surprising to see in russia
what do you have information about
the the spread of those demonstrations
their effectiveness their unexpectedness
any of that and and then on the world
front
what's happening there people seem
around the world seem to have united
in a quite remarkable manner
uh in a manner that isn't
working out in russia's favor let's say
and so
let's talk about the russian domestic
situation first and then the
international situation well we've seen
unprecedented uh sort of wide large
protests
uh against the war um including some
prominent personalities
and also just a lot of russians um on
the streets the you know the russians uh
purportedly arrested thousands of people
um in these protests and
or
that they claim were involved in the
protests i you know i don't i don't know
how many of them actually were
um and and it is surprising it's just
it's you know russians have been
conditioned to know that if you go out
and protest the odds of being arrested
are high
um and those are not jails that you want
to spend any time in so
um
it says a lot about the degree to which
putin had just really failed to prepare
his population for this war
uh i think they didn't i think russians
didn't think this was going to happen
for the excellent reason that russian
officials were telling them that it
wasn't going to happen right up until
the moment that it happened just about
uh days before like within 36 hours of
the actual russian invasion
russian senior officials were still
mocking the west for saying that the
russians were going to invade
so the russian people were caught by
surprise
and i think there's a there's an element
here that's very important because it
also it helps
it just contextualize a little bit the
conversation about how much the u.s
should or should not do to help the
ukrainians here including whether we
want to go to ukraine and fight and so
on which no one is
really suggesting and which i'm not
advocating now either
you know russian people we've seen
polling
please
as good polling as you can get from
russia
russian people see america as an enemy
they see nato as an enemy by large
margins
there's an old cold war hangover and
then there's what putin's been doing for
20 years to stoke that
they don't see ukraine as an enemy in
the in the same way and of course all of
the narrative and rhetoric coming out of
the kremlin has been that the ukraine
has sort of lost russian brothers in
many respects and the ukrainian
government the russians have terrible
things to say about but ukrainians
they say are you know our slavic
brothers and and fundamentally you know
belong in russia
and so i think
if this had been a war against the u.s
or a war against nato
uh putin could have expected to have a
certain resonance among his population
but i think
the fact that this is very purely a war
against ukraine
uh undermines a lot of the messages and
runs counter to a lot of
giving's people and
i think a lot of russians are just
saying themselves why
why are we doing this i mean that is
what they're saying people are saying
why are we doing this and as the
sanctions hit
and as the the economy gets worse
um i have sanctions ever been effective
in a situation like this before or is
there ever a situation like this before
well
look i mean in so in a certain
fundamental sense i don't think there
has been a situation like this where
we had uh
you know a u.s administration that was
saying very clearly we think the
russians are going to invade
and our strategy to to prevent them from
invading is to threaten them with
sanctions
and we're and saying we the us are not
going to enter the war so there's no
military deterrent on the table
and it's as pure and pristine a test as
you could really ever hope to have
of the theory that the threat of
crippling sanctions will deter
large-scale military action
and in that sense it has
demonstrated the the
weakness shall we say of that theory and
it is about as pristine an experiment as
you could hope for
i'm not surprised by it i never thought
that the threat of sanctions would deter
putin if he had decided to invade
and and they clearly didn't and i don't
think that they're going to
by themselves
uh persuade him to stop this fight
the ukrainians are in the process of
making a strong argument about why you
know continuing this war is not a good
idea from
uh putin's perspective
uh but i'm i'm not optimistic that he's
gonna you know come to that conclusion
soon and have you been surprised by the
response on the international front
i've been very gratified by it i mean
when you see the russians lose a vote in
the u.n general assembly by 141-5
you you i mean
putin that is that is an astonishing
failure of russian messaging information
operations and public diplomacy
when
listen the only former soviet state that
voted
against that resolution was belarus
which has 30 000 russian troops in it
you know even even the kazakhs even the
armenians didn't vote
um against that resolution they
abstained
that that's that's a sort of a
repudiation of a sword with even within
the within the russia dominated world
and then the the virtual unanimity of
the general assembly
um like you know on that resolution
is a devastating blow to putin's you
know narratives over many years that he
believes in collective
or in in um in multi-polarity that he
believes in the u.n that the un should
be the you know the arbiter of all of
these things he's thrown that back at
the u.s
uh for decades and to be repudiated by
the u.n as thoroughly as he just was
is a devastating blow for him
informationally now it's not going to
change his calculus
um
why did that happen what do you think is
oh sorry go ahead with that
you know why did that happen
it happened because you know as we
talked about um on on the last show
where we discussed this
you know i think the biden
administration very skillfully conducted
uh an information diplomatic uh campaign
that stripped away from putin
all of the efforts that he was uh making
to give himself any kind of
informational cover and make it look
like the ukrainians had started this or
prompted it or or generate any ambiguity
and then he decided to just big fat
invade anyway
without any kind of a fig leaf and
that has just made him so clearly the
aggressor even before he started uh
rubbling harkee what do you think the
biden administration did on that front
that was particularly effective
so
along with the threat of sanctions which
was not effective in deterring him um
the bidet administration did
really work hard to
learn about to penetrate russian plans
to conduct information operations to
conduct false flag attacks to try to
assassinate zelinski to try to conduct a
coup d'etat
and they publicized
what they learned they really were very
very fast to declassify intelligence and
publicize
all of the russian attempts to create
this this fictitious universe to
gaslight us
and persuade us that this is somehow
ukraine's fault of the ukrainians had
prompted this um and it was a very
skillful campaign that the bible
administration ran now you know i need
to be careful we need to be careful
about
over crediting them because
i think that they did
think
that by doing all of that they would
deter putin from attacking because they
were presenting him with the reality
that he would have to go in without any
informational cover and at the end of
the day putin decided he just didn't
care and he was going to go in anyway so
that the campaign failed
from the perspective of what it was i
think intended to do which was to deter
him but it did put him in this very bad
spot
where he's stripped of informational
cover he is nakedly the aggressor
and the international community at least
in the first week of this war
has largely with a couple of notable
exceptions
rallied against him in a way that we
really haven't seen it rally against
anyone since osama bin laden and that's
quite an accomplishment
what do you think might have constituted
a more appropriate strategy of
deterrence or
let's say
a more effective strategy of diplomacy
that might have avoided this altogether
or is that even possible
look
my my view all along has been that if
putin was willing to conduct this
invasion in order to achieve his aims
the only way that we were really going
to deter him from doing that would have
been by making it clear that we were
going to fight with the ukrainians and
we were going to guarantee his military
defeat
um i don't think anything short of that
and that's a tough that's a tough game
yeah because of course
the more that's put forward as the
strategy
the more the
fear let's say that's driving him
of
of the west
what of the westernization perhaps of
ukraine the more that also appears
justified in his eyes
yeah i i mean you know candidly i'm
happy to discuss that with you but
candidly that that counter argument
wasn't the one that impressed me the
most because
he's was already where he was on that
this is the putin is a guy who
understands force
and although i you know i and that and
the team at the institute for the study
of war have written for years about
how clever he's been with information
operations and hybrid war and lots of
other things at the end of the day putin
understands force
and if you take force off the table and
you tell him that he's not going to have
to worry about a forcible response
that shapes his calculation in a certain
direction if you put force on the table
and tell him that maybe he does have to
worry about
mixing it up with the american military
or nato then that would have changed
this calculation in a different
direction
and i think at a minimum because by the
way i want to be very clear that i
wasn't you know i wasn't advocating and
i'm not advocating now that we should
have said that we would have in you know
gone into ukraine and fought
in ukraine against the russians i
thought it was a very complicated series
of decisions we needed to make here and
i'm not going to second guess the
decision not to do that i will say
that it was in my view unfortunate that
president biden said and kept repeating
that we would not fight in ukraine
because i think that leaving ambiguity
in putin's mind on that question
would have been a good idea i don't know
that it would have been sufficient
though since he had decided that he was
prepared to do this
and why do you think the threat of
economic sanctions
wasn't as it wasn't a sufficient
deterrent
were was the threat credible and yeah
why do people who make such threats
assume that
the threat of economic sanction which i
suspect in some sense hits the ordinary
population harder than the leaders
why is that viewed as a credible
deterrent
look i mean on the one hand there's a
certain sort of mirror imaging here that
we you know we think about you know what
would we
how would we think about the world if we
were facing the kinds of sanctions that
we're imposing on russia
um
and you know how would sort of any
normal or ordinary person in putin's
position think about these things
because we can we are in a position to
devastate the russian economy and we are
devastating the russian economy
and that will matter to putin
uh russia's foreign reserves are not
infinite and they're not even that
extensive honestly and
uh war is incredibly expensive
especially when you're losing soldiers
and equipment at a rate he appears to be
uh he's going to need cash and having
his economy wrecked is going to make it
very hard to continue this war
among other things that he needs to do
and it's going to make his people very
unhappy and that will ultimately matter
to him
so if this it's this in the short term
it affects ordinary people and oligarchs
but in the longer term it will affect
him also in his ability to do stuff but
here's the thing
once somebody has decided that they are
prepared to try their luck by force of
arms
they've made a mental and psychological
shift
that it's easy for people on the outside
not to recognize because what you're
saying is i'm prepared to go in and i'm
prepared to kill a lot of people
and i'm prepared to lose a lot of my own
people
and i'm prepared to run the risk however
slight it might be that the war won't go
my way and really bad things will happen
if you're in that mindset
then the threat of economic sanctions is
not what is first and foremost in your
mind and i think we just
you know i think we a lot of people
collectively missed that putin had
gotten into that mindset
and then overestimated the sort of
rationality that is required then to
think about the long-term effects of
economic sanctions of a certain variety
so
what do you think
is going to happen and what do you think
we should want to have happen
in like if this could end in a
relatively
comparatively non-catastrophic manner
and does that mean that putin has to see
a way forward that still involves him
retaining control of russia
is there a way that he can do that
without
that would be acceptable to the west in
any real sense like
what would be our preconditions for
saying
this is over and we can move on what
should they be well i mean i think at
this point our basic precondition is
russians get the hell out of ukraine
um and stop attacking it and
then stop threatening to attack it um
you know
there will be there are russian war
crimes being committed there will be war
crimes trials conducted it's important
to hold russians accountable for the
terrible things they're doing
um
beyond that you know i i would
personally be prepared to accept it if
putin accepted the military defeat
withdrew his forces
um and
returned uh
you know returned ukrainian territory to
ukraine
i'd like to demand that he returned you
know donetsk and luhansk that he had all
you know uh occupied to begin with as
well as crimea
um
if i had to accept a piece
that had a russian military defeat
but that had russian forces still in
crimea
without of course recognizing crimea or
changing our position on that in any way
i would i would be inclined to accept
that
because at the best outcome that we
could hope for
and i'm not
optimistic that we will see this um
would be that the ukrainian military
with no more assistance than the
provision of weapons and supplies and so
forth that it's getting now maybe a
little bit more of that
defeats the russian military
conventionally and putin accepts the
defeat
that
that's the best possible outcome that we
could hope for
it will be a humiliation of the russian
military of a sort that it hasn't
experienced since the japanese
russo-japanese war of 1904 1905
and that's why unfortunately i don't
think putin can accept it
i think putin will feel obliged does
feel obliged to secure some military
victory of some variety
because as he keeps saying weakness is
lethal and being defeated by the
ukrainians
he will regard as intolerable but that's
the best outcome
that we that we could hope for and it's
what we are working for right now and
it's what we should continue to work for
as long as you think that what do you
think he might be pushed to accept as a
minimally acceptable military victory
i've got to tell you i'm i'm beyond the
point of being able to claim that i
really understand putin's thought
process at this point except to say that
i'm pretty confident that he will not be
able to accept emotionally and mentally
a straightforward defeat by the russian
military of the ukrainian military
without trying to escalate more
uh which i think he's doing right now
and so what do you hope that we continue
to do in the world outside ukraine and
russia
i hope that we continue to flow uh
weapons and supplies to the ukrainians
as fast as they need them
and i hope that we continue to provide
them with all of the support short of
actually deploying you know combat
forces or aircraft
uh to fight with them
and give them what they need i hope that
we
continue to unite the world against uh
putin for this uh outrageous unprovoked
act of aggression um and that we make it
very clear to putin that
his choices are going to be accepting
this defeat and making the best he can
of it um or really beginning to stare
down the barrel of the of the collapse
of his regime
um
that's but that all of that's very
tricky because when you start talking
about when you start putting the
collapse the regime on the table
right now we have a wounded angry bear
and animals like that are very
unpredictable and still can do a lot of
damage
and i so
this is something to be managed very
carefully and thoughtfully but i think
helping the ukrainians fight off this
attack
if forest comes to worst in ukraine or
one of the worst helping them prepare
for and conduct an insurgency
against russia
are important and then just continuing
to tighten the vice on putin and make it
clear
we will squeeze russia to death if he
does not back off
uh but we will not squeeze it to death
if he does back off i mean that's that
you know the off ramp here is if you do
stop this then we can you know we can
return to some kind of and you you think
that is a reasonable off ramp and
there's anyone that you regard as
credible suggesting any other
alternative to that
in terms of off-ramps um no um
and my problem with that off-ramp is it
requires putin to make a psychological
shift that i think is going to be almost
impossible for him of actually accepting
that he's been defeated here
um and that's right now i'm focused on
you know what can we do to make it clear
to him that he's not going to win this
without ourselves escalating in a way
that that will change this in a bad way
and i think that's the balance that that
everybody's trying to strike
um in terms of where putin will go
looking for off-ramps or other things at
that point
i'm nervous about a variety of ways that
that can go one of the things that putin
could do
is he could
really try to return this more into a
russia-nato conflict
which would likely rally his people more
enthusiastically than just a war against
ukraine
and i don't think that he's in a
position to attack nato militarily right
now given the problems that he has
but i think we should expect to see a
possible change in kremlin rhetoric and
posture
to try to make this more of a war to or
preparation to defend against nato and
rally
and
i think here again we need to not repeat
the mistake that we made that
contributed to this didn't cause this
putin you know we need to blame the
enemy for what the enemy did this was
putin's decision to invade biden
administration is not the blame for
putin's decision we need to be very
clear about that that would be true if
trump were in office or bush or anybody
else at the end of the day
putin made this decision and he's to
blame but the mistake the miscalculation
that by the administration made about
its ability to deter him we need to not
repeat that mistake
in when it comes to deterring him from
testing nato
i think we need to recognize that he is
engaged in a gunfight and we need to be
prepared to bring a gun to a gunfight so
the u.s has started to mobilize forces
to defend its niece to eastern nato
members we need to keep doing that there
will be more and more discussion about
how escalatory that might be and how
that might trip putin into
further activity i don't think that's
right
i think what we need to make clear to
putin is that if he starts something
with nato we will finish it quickly
and there is nothing there for him and
not allow him to imagine that there is
any even initial military success he
could achieve against nato because we
just need to foreclose that option
preventing this from becoming a russia
nato war is a very big priority right
now as well as helping ukrainians defeat
the russians in ukraine yeah well it
also
means
failing
in some sense to take into account the
u.n decision because it's not just nato
that's
right rallying behind the ukraine but
behind the brain it seems like
in the most real of senses it's the
entire world
most of it and i think we need to get
after the parts of the world that aren't
rallying
um i think look we need to look at the
at india and say listen you know it's
actually not okay that that india
abstained on that resolution
it's not okay
um you know i understand various
countries have various calculations but
this is this is not a time for those
kinds of calculations so i'm thrilled
that it was 141 to 5 but there should
have been more countries voting for that
resolution and i i think we need to
focus on doing everything we can to
increase that
isolation that putin feels
and have the countries that abstained
going to him and saying listen you know
listen for the diminutive of of vladimir
but you know listen forever this isn't
going to happen for you and we we can't
we can't carry water for you even in
this limited way you're going to have to
make a decision
to end this on terms that you don't like
that message has got to be coming to him
from all of his
friends and all of the people who are
straddling right now as well so i think
you're absolutely right jordan that
finding ways to continue to strengthen
this global uh block against him is
important
okay
all right well i think unless you have
anything to add to that that seems like
a reasonable update um
the news could be worse given how bad
the situation is
and uh it's quite remarkable i think to
see
the essential unity of the world in
response to this and the fact that
it didn't
that ukraine wasn't as easy a bite to
chew as might have been expected to
begin with and i can't see that really
getting much better for
for the russians for putin in the near
future
hopefully not um
ukrainian
slave glory to ukraine
thanks very much for speaking with me
again and we'll be in touch again when
it seems like the appropriate thing to
do thank you so much jordan all right